NEVER, MY OPEN.
IT’S TIME FOR THE LEFT TO FOLD
UP THEIR FANTASY TENT.
IF THEY HATE DONALD TRUMP SO
MUCH MAYBE THEY SHOULD FOCUS ON
WINNING THE 020 ELECT INSTEAD OF
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION NONSENSE
THAT’S BEEN WASTING OUR MONEY
AND TWIERGD OUR NATION FOR TWO
YEARS.
A NONSTOP PERSONAL VENDETTA BY
MUELLER AND HIS TRUMP-HATING
PROSECUTORS IS SO INTENSE THEY
BEAT HAIR LEFTIST CHEST ANY TIME
THEY ISSUE AN INDICTMENT AGAINST
THEY ISSUE AN INDICTMENT AGAINSTSOMEONE, ANYONE, MOST OF OF WHOM
SOMEONE, ANYONE, MOST OF OF WHOM
LIVE IN RUSSIA.
OR HAVE BEEN INDICTED FOR EVENT
THAT PRECEDED TRUMP.
OR FOR LYING TO THE FBI WHICH
RELATER FIND OUT WASN’T
CONSIDERED AS A LIE BY THE FBI
ACTED.
STORIES SO -- OR IS SO SERIOUS
ONE GUY GOT A WHOPPING 14 DAYS
IN JAIL.
NONE OF THIS HAS TIED THE
PRESIDENT TO RUSSIA.
BUT YOU WOULDN’T KNOW IT FROM
THESE GUYS.
>> A LOT PAPER HERE.
BUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES DIRECTED A CRIME.
>> WE HAVE A SITTING PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WHO COMMIT
TWO FELONIES WHILE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> IF HISTORY MEANS ANYTHING IN
THE TRUMP ERA, DONALD TRUMP WILL
BE, MUST BE IMPEACHED BECAUSE OF
THE CRIMES PROSECUTORS SAY HE
COMMITTED IN THE MICHAEL COHEN
CASE.
>> ROBERT MUELLER IS SAYING HERE
CONGRESS, HERE IS AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE, YOU DECIDE.
>> I THINK WHAT THE TOTALITY OF
TODAY’S FILINGS SHOW, THE HOUSE
IS GOING TO HAVE LITTLE CHOICE
THE WAY THIS IS GOING OTHER THAN
TO START IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
JUDGE JEANINE: DID THE PRESIDENT
DIRECT A FELONY?
IF MICHAEL COHEN WHO IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST OF FLAWED
PROSECUTION WITNESSES I HAVE
EVER SEEN IS RELIED UPON TO
PROVE BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
THAT DONALD TRUMP CIRCUMVENTED
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS, THEY
MIGHT AS WELL BE WHISTLING DIXIE
UP THE MIS.
NUMBER ONE, IF THE PRESIDENT
DIRECT ANY PAYMENT, WHY?
WHAT WAS HIS STATE OF MIND?
WHAT WAS HE THINKING?
WHAT WASN’T HE THINKING?
DO YOU THINK MICHAEL COHEN
KNOWS?
MAYBE HE DIDN’T WANT HIS WIFE TO
FIND OUT.
MAYBE HE DIDN’T WANT HIS FAMILY
TO FIND OUT.
MAYBE HE WAS TRYING TO PREVENT
ANY TARNISH ON HIS BRAND.
OR MAYBE TO SIMPLY GET THE WOMAN
OFF HIS BACK.
IT WOULDN’T BE THE FIRST TIME A
HIGH-PROFILE PERSON PAID TO GET
RID OF A NUISANCE LAWSUIT.
THERE IS A PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE IN HE CRIMINAL CASE
AND EVERY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, AND NEVER A
PRESUMPTION AGAINST THAT WITHOUT
EVIDENCE THAT ACTS ARE DONE FOR
PURELY CRIMINAL REASONS.
AND DON’T FORGET, IT WAS CITIZEN
DONALD TRUMP’S MONEY THAT WAS
USED AND NOT CAMPAIGN MONEY FOR
WHATEVER MIGHT HAVE OCCURRED
BEFORE HE WAS PRESIDENT, UNLIKE
ANOTHER PRESIDENT IMPEACHED FOR
ACTS THAT OCCURRED WITH A YOUNG
INTERN IN THE OVAL OFFICE WHILE
HE WAS PRESIDENT.
SO FAR 30 MILLION TAXPAYER
DOLLARS FOR THIS NONSENSE IS
NONSENSE.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE BARACK OBAMA
WAS IN A POSITION TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT SO-CALLED
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE BUT DID
NOTHING EXCEPT TO TELL PUTIN TO
KNOCK IT OFF.
AND EVEN THAT I DON’T BELIEVE.
AS FOR THE TESTIMONY OF HOLIER
THE RULES DON’T APPLY TO HIM AND
THAN THOU JAMES COMEY WHO THINKS
FOUGHT SO HARD TO TESTIFY IN AN
OPEN SETTING.
WHY DID YOU WANT YOUR TESTIMONY
BEFORE HOUSE AND JUDICIARY AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES TO BE IN
PUBLIC.
JIM, YOU READILY ADMITTED 250
TIMES THAT YOU DIDN’T RECALL OR
DIDN’T REMEMBER.
HONESTLY, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN AND
IS LESS EMBARRASSING FOR TO YOU
DO IT BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
BUT SLIPPERY JIM SAYS HE DOESN’T
REMEMBER IMPORTANT FACTS ABOUT
THE MOST OF IMPORTANT FISA CASE
IN AMERICAN HISTORY THAT
REQUIRED HIS APPROVAL.
HE THINKS IT DOESN’T MATTER
WHERE THE FAKE DOSSIER CAME
FROM.
YET HE STILL HAS TOTAL
CONFIDENCE IN THE FISA PROCESS
THAT HE CORRUPTED.
NOW I DON’T HAVE TO GO OVER THIS
AGAIN.
COMEY HAS BEEN FOUND BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO HAVE
MISHANDLED THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
TO HAVE LIED BEFORE CONGRESS NOT
ABOUT EXONERATING HILLARY BEFORE
THE INVESTIGATION WAS DONE.
AND TO BE AN ADMITTED LEAKER OF
SENSITIVE INFORMATION THAT HE
WANTED TO GET TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" THROUGH HIS FRIEND.
WHEN ASKED IF HE WOULD HAVE
FIRED THE LOVERS ON HIS AFTER,
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE, WHO
OPRY COMMUNICATED THEIR HATRED
AND DISDAIN FOR CANDIDATE DONALD
TRUMP.
COMEY SAYS HE CAN’T ANSWER IN
THE ABSTRACT.
DOESN’T DENY HE WOULD HAVE
ALLOWED THEM TO STAY ON THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION IN SPITE
OF THEIR HATE AS LONG AS THEY
GAVE AN EXPLANATION.
NO SURPRISE, JIM, SINCE YOU ARE
A PAL OF THE CLINTONS.
THE MOST OF SHOCKING IS COMEY’S
ROLE IN THE THEATER OF THE
ABSURD.
A FAKE DOSSIER PAID FOR BY A
WOMAN WHO IS HIS FRIEND RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
AND HE IS BEST FRIEND WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN CHARGE OF THE
CASE.
AND HE DOESN’T REMEMBER KEY
DETAILS LIKE THE PARTY WHO
FUNDED IT IN THE MOST OF BLATANT
DISPLAY OF PUBLIC CORRUPTION AND
PERSONAL POLITICAL COVER IN